- Welcome back to Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous, and I'm the technical director
of Education at IBM Quantum.
This is the second lesson of the series. If you haven't already
watched the first lesson, be sure to check it out.
We'll be building directly on what we talked about
in the first lesson, so it's important to have an
understanding of that material going into this lesson.
Also, be aware that the series
includes textbook content in addition to videos, and you can find a link
to the textbook content
in the video description. This is lesson two of
unit one of the series.
Unit one covers the basics
of quantum information.
In the previous lesson, we talked about quantum information in the setting of single systems, meaning that we have one
system that stores information
and we're describing how
it works in isolation.
We spent a fair amount of
time on classical information, mainly to establish a point of reference and to highlight the
mathematical similarities
between quantum and classical information.
We also saw how quantum states can be represented by vectors, specifically vectors having
complex number entries and Euclidean norm equal to one,
and we discussed standard
basis measurements and unitary operations.
In this lesson, we're gonna expand our
view to multiple systems, each of which is capable of
storing quantum information.
This is not simply a matter of saying that each individual system
works as we discussed last time, there is a sense in which the hole
is greater than the sum of the parts, and that's also true of
classical information when probabilities are involved.
Multiple systems can
interact with one another and they can be correlated
with one another for instance, and in the quantum setting, this includes the possibility
that the systems are entangled, which is a term that you
may have heard about before.
Entanglement is a very
important phenomenon in quantum information and we'll have a lot more to say about it as the series continues.
There is a simple principle, however, that offers us quite a lot of traction for thinking about and
understanding quantum information for multiple systems,
and that is that we can always
take two or more systems and put them together or just conceptually
think about them together
and view them as if they form
a single compound system.
And when we think about a
compound system like this, as if it's a single system, we recognize that it must be described in a way that's consistent
with everything we learned
in the previous lesson on single systems.
We'll see how this works
and how the description of quantum information
from multiple systems emerges pretty naturally from how it works for single systems
based on this one principle. Here's an overview of the lesson and it happens to be identical to the previous lessons overview,
but this time our focus
will be on multiple systems rather than single systems.
Just like we did in the previous lesson and for exactly the same reasons, we're going to start with
classical information.
Once again, we'll see
very close similarities between the way that quantum
and classical information work at a mathematical level.
We won't typically focus so
much on classical information or start each lesson in the series with classical information like this.
Subsequent lessons will tend to be focused much more exclusively on quantum information and computation.
But here at the beginning
this is a sensible approach and it goes back to the idea that thinking about classical information
can serve as a valuable source of guidance for understanding quantum information.
We're also gonna discuss
the important concept of a tensor product in
this part of the lesson.
Tensor products are critically important in quantum information, but they also arise in
the classical setting.
Then we'll move on to quantum information and much like in the previous lesson we'll discuss quantum states,
standard basis measurements,
and unitary operations this
time for multiple systems.
We'll start by talking
about classical states of multiple systems.
Recall from the previous
lesson that a classical state of a system is a
configuration of that system that can be recognized and
described unambiguously
without any uncertainty or error. And in mathematical terms, when we refer to a classical state set,
we just mean a finite and non-empty set.
We'll begin our discussion
of multiple systems by supposing that we have
just two systems X and Y.
X has some set of classical states which we'll call sigma just
like in the previous lesson, and y has some set of classical states
that we'll call gamma. The set sigma and gamma
could be the same set or they could be different,
but we're giving them different names, not only because they
could be different sets, but also because it'll help
us to keep things clear if we give them different names.
We'll find that it's
pretty easy to generalize this entire discussion from two systems to any number of systems, but
by starting with two systems,
we can focus on the fundamental ideas without getting bogged down in details.